- Now it's different, right?
'Cause this is the second time,
they have context now.
Yeah!
- Yeah!
- [Gary] You've got your perspective.
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
- [Gary] I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(jazzy hip hop music)
- One of our guys shows up here.
Wanna tell 'em the story?
- [Female] Yes, tell it.
- He shows up with weed in his backpack.
We go downstairs, they
gotta check everyone's bag.
- Fuck.
- So I go, put it in your pocket.
I don't know what you
thought was gonna happen
at this thing anyway, right, bro?
So he goes, no, I got like
(laughs)
- Like a lot.
- Weed
- [Man] Talking about!
So,
- Why couldn't he keep it on the bus?
- [Man] 'Cause
- He was scared it was gonna disappear?
I know why he thought to
not keep it on the bus,
he didn't want somebody
to fuckin' take it!
- [Man] My man is sittin' in the cut
the whole time.
Not, interacting,
doesn't look like he's interacting
with anything you're saying, right?
We leave, Sean takes us to
another room down the hall,
and I go, well look,
now the camera's aren't on us.
What's everyone think?
What's your takeaway from this?
And he sits back and he goes,
"Yo, Reynolds,
"I don't need all this shit."
He goes, "But, I can never go back to
"what I was doing before,
"and doing the same dumb stuff."
That was almost two years ago.
My man moved out of West Philly.
He used to sell drugs on
the corner of West Philly,
and, for real,
that was, we walked out of here
and he was like, that's it.
That's the switch.
And so, I appreciate you taking this time
because that's the game.
The game is, let me get you
out of what you're used to.
And if you can see it,
I think you can really
be it in a lot of ways.
- It's really fucking crazy, right?
Because, it's crazy to me that
one sentence from,
and it's happened to all of us,
it's happened to me!
Once,
I mean, it happens with,
that's why people fuck with music so much.
One sentence at one
moment, at the right time
just changes
(laughs)
it's crazy!
And to think,
I didn't know that's something I could do.
To think like that, in
the last couple years,
I'm like, wait a minute.
And obviously, look,
when you're younger, you're more moldable.
You're not further along in your thinking.
Obviously, what's uniquely interesting
for me at this point, is
Instagram is so important
to everyone's attention,
it's no different than if I was like
winning on MTV in 1992.
Right?
It's why Diddy won!
He was so smart, he just crashed TRL!
And just would always show up,
'cause he knew the youth
was on watching that.
That now is Instagram.
Right?
And so no matter how
much any of the kids here
may want, either
Now it's different, right?
'Cause this is the second time.
They have context now.
But even if they left, like, 'ehh',
but when they go in the van
and two hours later and
they look on Instagram
and they see Lil Baby or Gunna
or Lil Keed givin' me love,
they're like, wait a minute.
That's just truth!
That's just how it works.
And so right now I know I
have that responsibility.
When NBA players and
rappers think I'm cool,
inevitably that means an
entire generation of youth
is gonna think I'm cool.
And I'm speakin' some real shit!
The end.
And now it flipped for me too.
It flipped and, obviously that clip,
a lot of people saw and it's like
a great clip.
My belief is that if
you're a great drug dealer,
you'd be a great business man.
I just believe that,
'cause it's the same game!
There's a lot of drug
dealers that suck at it!
(laughs)
Right?
Look at my man Moose.
He's breaking down these bags into nickels
because he's making more money that way,
and he's chincing,
he's actually making three dollar bags,
but he realizes that
everybody at the school
doesn't know the fuckin' difference
and doesn't care!
He's smart!
So, if you're good at it,
or if somebody's
(laughs)
somebody's good at it,
they'd be even better
at flipping sneakers,
or gear or going to the thrift store
and flipping,
because it's the same fucking move!
A great clip.
I know it is!
Do you get hit up about that?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Man] A lot of people
was talking to me.
It was crazy, he texted me one morning.
I was like, you serious?
- Dude, you're on WorldStar right now.
(laughs)
- [Man] This a joke,
but it was really good
to be back in this space is great, man.
I never thought I could do this, 'cause,
the way you were talking
to us in the first video,
you said you want us to
come back in 10, 15 years.
I'm like, dude!
I can't even see that far ahead!
- Kev started DM'ing you,
the day after, for a year and a half.
And then we get Alexander who was like,
I'm like, yo,
this is some front.
This is not the real thing.
So anyway, that was
- It's just so incredible.
So, probably around that time,
maybe six months earlier,
maybe six months after,
I was like, fuck, now
it's a responsibility.
Which is heavy!
Right?
I don't know what else to say.
I'm in a weird spot in my life,
where I'm like, fuck, I'm uniquely a human
that can penetrate 15 to
25 year old alpha dudes
and speak to them in some way
that makes them actually see it different.
And there's nothing else to say.
And now it's like, it's heavy.
And it's super, I'm grateful.
But it's different.
I don't know what else to say.
- [Woman] Tells you to watch what you say?
- Not really.
(laughs)
You know what's funny?
No, actually, I answer it a funny way,
it's a really great question.
It makes me not want to
become a caricature of myself.
The biggest thing I'm scared,
it doesn't make me watch what I say,
'cause first of all,
the reason 15 year old
kids will listen to me
is because I speak in a
way that is unfiltered
and truthful and
when parents hit me up, they're like,
'hey, I love your message'
'cause I'm talking really good stuff.
They're like, 'but you're cursing',
I'm like, motherfucker, do you understand
your kids only listen
to me 'cause I curse?
It just feels more real.
It's not,
what, you think your 13
year old doesn't hear shit?
You know.
- [Man] I saw a video post by you
and you're talking to some guy,
he was a rapper.
You asked him, are you confident in music?
And he said no.
And I was like, really surprised by that,
'cause I do music and I'm very confident
in what I do.
I took the time out of my day
learning how to do it all by myself.
And figure it out.
And I wanted to know,
what was your,
how do you explain to rappers
how you get your music out there
in order to,
that's my problem.
I can make great music,
I can make good sounding music and do it
on my own, I learned how
to mix, master, produce
and all that stuff by myself.
How do you take it to another level?
- It's just exposure, man.
You decided it's good.
The market hasn't yet.
Right?
So, the biggest thing,
some people are insecure
and think their shit sucks
and it's amazing.
And some people think their shit's amazing
and they're delusional and it sucks!
The great part about this world is
you, and I might have brought this up
when the crew was here last time,
because of the college I went to,
every one of my friends
wanted to be a rapper.
Right?
And I remembered being blown away
that they weren't putting in the work.
I was like, get a job at Kmart,
'I can't afford time
in the studio', right?
What's up?
- [Man] Hustle and grind.
Get the money in your pocket
so you can start with studio time.
Try to get your grind up,
try to get your music out.
If you work at Kmart
- That's right.
That was my big thing with them.
But what's crazy now is actually,
you guys don't have to do that!
Because of technology and distribution,
all you have to do is make music
and then instead of working at Kmart
for 57 hours a week, a month or whatever,
and then get studio time
and bang out one thing,
now those 57 hours,
after you make the music,
is just about DM'ing people
and just trying to get on!
Your one DM,
I would literally make music,
then lay in bed until Instagram blocked me
from DM'ing people,
from,
Playboi Carti down to a
meme page that needs music.
From Savage to fuckin' WorldStar to
somebody, a booty girl, I don't care!
(laughs)
Just somebody to listen.
I mean, I think people are very confused,
PnB Rock got big because
Kylie had one little Snap.
And people heard it in the back.
It's just real!
That's how music works.
What's amazing about music is
you're one hit away from
everything changing.
And what people don't think
about is distribution.
They think about making the music.
And then they play within their own head
like 'it's good, it's better.
'Why are all these people hitting?
'My shit's better.'
'Cause nobody heard it!
But the fact that you could
upload it to Soundcloud and Spotify
for free!
I mean, I promise you,
the 39 to 74 year old versions of you
who are watching this right now,
they're like, yes!
Speak it to that kid.
I used to have, we didn't have a shot!
We didn't have a shot!
We had to go in midtown
and give out our CD's
and we had to pray that Run DMC saw it,
it was like winning the lotto!
It's not winning the lotto anymore.
You just upload your shit!
I mean it, you upload every fuckin' song
every day, whatever
and then you just DM people and say,
yo, listen to my shit!
There's nothing else!
- [Man] You taught me about patience,
it took a long time for
you to get back to me
but I knew once you got back to me,
it was so
(laughs)
unbelievable!
I was like, this man
finally got back to me!
(laughs)
It was unbelievable, you
just taught me the game!
And everything you said,
I didn't understand it right away.
I needed some time to watch more content,
once I understood, I
was like, yo I got this.
And that's how I got back here today.
So I'm just grateful.
- I love you, man.
That's one of my favorite clips ever.
Just watching your
right there, just your eyes.
It's the best, man, feels so good.
It's so real.
That advice I gave you is real.
Literally one time you're
gonna DM some blogger
and they're gonna put it in their vlog
and your life will be different.
If it's good.
It's just crazy.
You kids have it so much better.
I'm being dead
(laughs)
- [Man] I'm trying to tell them that
every single day.
- 'Cause you know!
And they think it's cliche, like,
it's just not.
It's not like the old school stuff
like 'you have it better',
'cause people did, incrementally.
You jumped like 10 spots.
'Cause the internet is neutral.
The internet has no feelings!
Has no prejudice, has no feelings,
has no assumptions.
Has no tendencies,
doesn't care about anybody
more than anybody.
It's just there!
Somebody was crying this morning,
I was on Twitter.
They're like, 'fuckin' Instagram!
'Not getting the reach anymore,
'us artists are getting fucked,
'can't get as many people seein' it.
'Now they want us to pay, motherfucker,
'Fuck Facebook and Instagram',
I replied, I'm like,
shit's free!
I'm like, what do you mean
they're taking away your shit?
It's free!
(laughs)
They're like, oh I didn't
think about that way.
(laughs)
It's free!
- [Woman] People like to complain
or blame it on an algorithm.
- Right!
Because they were smart and got on early,
so they had more value,
but they became entitled.
They didn't know what they had
until it goes away.
- [Woman] So how do you work within
the constraints of algorithms
for Facebook and Instagram
and those sort of things?
- It's the way we live
in constraints of society
and things of that nature.
You have to accept.
Everything has constraints.
You have to accept, and
you have to understand
your constraints can
become your advantages.
Instagram's fuckin' you?
Maybe it's now time to start your podcast!
Get your YouTube up.
Figure out Facebook.
'Facebook's corny'?
Cool, I like attention.
(laughs)
You know what I mean?
- So one thing that I really,
I'm trying to do now is that
I have my music on Spotify
my music is all over the place,
but one thing I'm trying
to really focus on now is
I probably wanna go
I had an idea to make YouTube videos.
That's what I used to
do before I did music.
- [Gary] Yep, I get it.
- But, I was gonna make videos,
go out to different places downtown
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
- Philadelphia
- [Gary] Yep.
- And I was gonna ask
people to listen to my music
and see what they thought about it.
- That's fine too!
I will tell you right now,
by the way, I like that.
You're doing something.
Everybody's just debating
shit in their head,
talking to their friends about
what they're 'gonna' do.
The fact that you're doing something's
already exciting the fuck outta me.
I'm gonna tell you something
I really believe in.
You need to lay in your fuckin' bed
and DM until Instagram blocks you
and then go to sleep and
wake up the next morning
and be like, fuck,
back to patience, fuck, nobody replied.
Gary's wrong.
Do it again the next day,
then the next day,
and then for some unknown fuckin' reason,
Young Thug decided to listen to it,
and your whole life will
change, if it's good.
- [Woman] When do you give up?
- Never!
And here's why.
You don't give up,
(crosstalk)
if it's good.
The market will tell you!
My big thing is if you
want to be a music star,
what's up, why is it so scary to
waste an hour before you go to sleep?
You're on Instagram looking
at pretty girls anyway!
The fuck are you doing anyway?
(laughs)
You're on Instagram anyway!
You're going to sleep that way anyway!
So instead of watching
basketball highlights
or boxing highlights or pretty girls or,
just work!
If you want something, you gotta work.
That is never gonna change.
No internet, no shminternet, no fuckin',
we all move to Mars.
You want something, you gotta work.
But people would rather
complain about how it is
than put in the work.
People would rather
default into why they can't
than putting in the actions
that allow them to can.
Here's the biggest thing about that.
The only people that are listening to you
are other losing players.
The only other people that are
co-signing your excuses
are other losers.
- Can I just,
can I ask you about providing value?
'Cause I don't really still get that,
but when I DM'ed you, I
DM'ed countless other,
tell 'em.
- John Travolta is Kev's dude, right?
He's the only kid I know that has
Welcome Back Carter on DVD.
(laughs)
- And I started DM'ing
everybody from him to
Ray Liotta to Martin Scorsese,
I was going down the list
- And?
- And I still waited.
I'm still waitin' now.
- So here's what I would say.
Start over, and go with this.
Hey, I know you're busy as shit.
I have unlimited sweat for you.
(laughs)
- [Man] Just like that?
- Just like that.
I have unlimited sweat
equity, I will work.
You want to get coffee?
Cool.
You want me to edit shit?
I don't know what you do,
everybody, listen.
Everybody's either got
money, talent or time.
And if you don't know
what your talent is yet,
and you have no money,
you got time!
You got seven hours for Martin Scorsese!
So, the biggest problem is
when people hit up people,
they're asking for something
instead of trying to give something.
Set the tone from the get!
Be like, I got time for you.
I'll tell you, if you
what's so great about being young,
a lot of youngsters do
have creative talents
'cause you guys grew up in the internet
where making shit came natural
that we didn't grow up with.
So, listen, every one of
one of the things I think
everybody should be doing,
so many people trying to
get to athletes and rappers
that are good at video and
editing and all that shit.
I'm like, make shit for people!
It's mindset, it's EQ.
It's optimism, it's,
this is just the this game.
It just is, it's a this game.
You can't start doing any of this
until this is right.
This is broken, you're fucked.
You're just going through the motions.
- What does that look like though?
So, for these guys,
what does that
- To me, it looks like
waking up and realizing,
whatever adversity they think they have,
it's actually their biggest strength!
They're not soft!
Being an African-American in America
immediately defaults
you into not being soft.
And that's huge!
That's huge!
It's true, it's true!
And you could be the most wealthy,
and obviously, that makes it easier,
but you could be the richest,
and you're still gonna
be profiled and judged.
It's just true.
And I think that's an advantage
in the way the world's going now,
'cause the world's playing
out on the internet
where the internet doesn't judge that.
That's how I see it.
Either I'm gonna be historically correct
or I'm gonna be wrong, but
the opportunity is endless.
There were humans that made decisions
in the '40s, '50s, '60s, '70s, '80s, '90s.
of who was gonna win and
who wasn't gonna win.
There was humans!
There is no Sally Spotify, it's Spotify.
It's not Sacha Soundcloud,
it's Soundcloud.
It's platforms.
That's why so much is happening now.
- I feel like one of the
things I hear you saying too,
and I think it's important
for these guys is
not being loyal to a particular platform.
- [Gary] That's for sure.
- I mean it looks like
you're all over the place
all the time
on every platform.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Could you,
but there's,
the 'gram is the cool
thing right now, right?
If you're on Instagram.
- [Gary] Everything I
see doesn't make me fear
Instagram going anywhere so quick.
But like, of course, if you're a creator,
or you're trying to build a personal brand
or you're trying to sell t-shirts
or whatever you're up to,
diversity.
Right?
Can't be vulnerable.
MySpace was the hottest shit.
(laughs)
Wasn't even an app!
- Yeah.
- So what about,
is there any concern for
you have, 6,000 people
following you on Instagram,
you only have 200 on Facebook,
why you wasting time putting
stuff out on Facebook?
- Short term thinking
versus long term thinking.
That was the switch, you know?
Sure, right now.
So start making everyone,
every other tenth post on
your Instagram be like,
yo follow me on these things too.
- [Man] You said,
as far as, when you say provide value,
and giving them something,
when I asked you,
I just wanted this.
I ain't want nothing
else, I just wanted this.
And then glad that these
guys can come along and
learn from a teacher,
'cause he did it for me.
And I just wanted to do it back for him.
And I wanted to do it for me
'cause it's a great experience.
Talked some of the
realest shit in the world,
I mean, it's ridiculous!
It's crazy, I mean
- I get it.
- That's all I wanted
- That's the best part because
then what happens is once you start,
once people understand that
giving actually creates you getting,
shit gets real interesting.
It's hard to think that.
'Cause people think it means you're soft,
people were so scared of somebody
taking advantage of them.
I've never in my life thought about
somebody taking advantage of me.
I gave!
I didn't expect to get anything from it.
You can't take advantage of somebody
who's giving with no expectation.
Everybody's got bullshit pride.
It's insecurity.
- So my title at the
school is a janitor, right?
So, every morning, they want
me to clean up after them.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Group] Whoa, whoa!
- Okay, so
(laughs)
so now that I'm explaining to them
my job title, you see the
reaction that I'm getting.
- Why is that happening?
- Great question,
because I do so much more
- Got it.
- Than clean up after them.
- Got it, got it.
- You understand?
- That's the official title.
- The official title.
(crosstalk)
But the beauty behind it is
- You guys are a fucking
class, that's why,
he's strategic!
He's strategic!
- Nah nah nah
- [Man] I never knew that
- Right.
So I say that to say,
they don't know where I came from.
They don't know how many people I put on
- Sure.
- That I watch on TV every single day.
- I love it.
- And they never call back and say,
here goes a check for you, thank you.
- [Gary] Yeah of course not.
- You know what I'm saying?
So, it is for free.
- [Gary] And it's
not why you're doing it.
- No, but I'm creating
a dome over that free
and now I have freedom
- [Gary] 100 percent
- [Man] To do what I want.
- 100 percent.
- [Man] When I want.
They still see me as
the one that's
(crosstalk)
- I've been in school for four years,
I have never seen you hold a broom.
(laughs)
- Tell us to go get a broom
or something to go clean.
(crosstalk)
(laughs)
- It's strategy.
- [Man] Yo go get a broom from the back,
go clean it up.
- I'll get to you in a minute,
let me see
anybody who hasn't asked anything,
any questions, thoughts?
- Actually I do right here, so
- You go next.
- You know I'm a Senior in high school.
Always stated my future every day,
I know a lot of people say,
oh don't think so far into the future
but I feel like I have to,
because I wanted to see what my self is
like five to 10 years from now.
- Being thought, real quick,
being thoughtful about
the future is amazing,
but not letting it cripple you is the key.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause my problem be
I would think so further in the future,
I would start worrying about stuff.
Stuff that I want to accomplish
before I leave this Earth,
years from now that I want to do.
- It's great to have ambition
- Yeah yeah, that's
- But if you cast too
much judgment on yourself
on a day to day on how you're
reaching that ambition,
you're going to cripple yourself.
- So,
- You know?
Having ambition's amazing.
- Yeah.
- But if you're like, ah fuck,
I want to be the President
of the United States,
what the fuck did I do about that today?
You're gonna lose.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- I always would see a
lot of videos from you
and I'll watch, sometimes, Eric Thomas
- Yep.
- He speaks to me a lot
'cause I'll watch it
with my stepdad sometimes
go work out, go to the gym so like
I seen that video
I watched it this past week,
you two guys were doing the video together
but my thing is,
I would always so think
further in the future that
I would always worry about
the bad things that can happen
instead of the good things.
- Yep.
- 'Cause I put so much focus on
what can go wrong and what can go right?
So what can you tell me that
- Well first of all, the fact that
you even understand that to be true
means you're halfway home.
I'm being dead serious with you.
The fact that you understand
that that is your perspective
means you're on the cusp of fixing it.
- I just need to know now,
I'm 18 years old.
- My only thing that I've
ever seen really work
in this scenario, where your
DNA and your experiences
has made you look half glass full,
pessimistic versus optimistically blind
is
to fundamentally surround yourself
with optimistic people.
And optimistic thoughts.
Straight up.
- Okay.
- The only thing
that I've ever really seen change people
is other people.
You gotta cut out, it's real simple.
You gotta cut out
pessimistic and negativity,
and you gotta add on
optimism and positivity.
It's as simple as that.
I've never seen it work any other way.
- [Woman] Say it again?
- I will.
The only way I think you can get there is
to recognize who else
is in your inner circle.
I'm talking family.
Friends.
- Down to that too.
- What's that?
- I know it gets down to that too.
- It does.
It's the people around you,
are they spittin' negative shit, woe is
if you're around somebody
who no matter what
is like, see?
We're never gonna,
you know?
That's what you believe!
And then if,
you can't, I don't believe in firing
your parents or your sister,
I feel in limiting your exposure to them
- Yeah.
- But then, and in that limitation,
adding on,
you guys should be looking
around at each other
and whoever else isn't here.
And in order, who's the most optimistic?
There's a real fine line
between delusion and optimism.
'I'm gonna be in the League',
but they're not even practicing?
(laughs)
So that's delusion.
I'm gonna be in the league,
and maybe you don't see it
but you see them at
least doing free throws
5am to 6am every morning
before they go on the bus.
At least he's trying.
- At least he's doing something.
- 100 percent, that effort matters.
There are so many guys in the League
that fuckin', nobody
saw it in high school.
Because people didn't see the talent,
they weren't putting up the stats,
but they were putting in the work.
And by the way, there's a million people
that put in the work,
they just don't have the talent!
I'd be in every league if I had talent!
(laughs)
I'd be fuckin' Deon 3.0!
You know I'd play all four
I'd be in it, but I
don't have that talent,
but I have that work
ethic, I had that mindset.
So, I really believe what
I'm about to tell you
and it's a big thing for
everybody in this room.
And the more difficult
your circumstances are,
the more likely you're around pessimism.
The problem is, all the
kids that have all the money
on the Upper East Side and Upper West Side
and have it real good,
they've got the reverse.
They have it so good it's delusion.
So it's like two sides of the same coin.
Either you have too too little,
or you have too too much.
I used to,
I believe what's happened now is
because of the way the internet works,
the people who have too little
have the actual advantage, not
the people who have too much.
That's crazy.
It's game changing for this conversation.
It's why when I go and speak to
a private school,
I'm like, hey,
shit's turning the other way on you.
You think granddaddy's
gonna take care of it,
the internet's taking over.
So I think you need to
my number one piece of
advice of leaving here is
whoever the most
optimistic person is here,
become more friendly with them.
Straight up.
Or if you got an aunt
and she's optimistic,
her!
I mean it.
It's only people.
Or what's in your ears.
Right?
More Eric Thomas optimism and work,
less somebody singing about
suicide and pessimism,
it's not gonna work out.
When I watch those type videos
like you or Eric Thomas,
how hard he speaks.
- Yeah he comes at it!
- It's like,
when he says something about a person,
like, dang, that's
something I'm doing wrong
that I should change.
Then it hits me hard,
like okay, now I know
- And that's the beauty of
the game right now, right?
Eric or I, there's millions of people.
A lot of people have
very similar thematics,
we just all have different
communication styles.
Different adjectives, different styles,
and that's how people find the person
that speaks to them.
Mix it up, you know.
- Definitely.
Appreciate that.
- How much time do I have?
Five?
We'll make it 10.
I'll adjust.
You knew I was gonna get stuck in here.
(laughs)
- I'm not really into all the video
- Yep, good.
- I wanna be a teacher.
- Okay.
- Somebody I want to do
- It's amazing.
- I want to be the best teacher
- Great.
- That's what I wanna do.
I wanna hear
- Yeah, please.
- How often, my father, my mom
they often tell me like,
you're not going to make a lot of money.
- They're right.
- That's not really, I don't
- You don't need to!
- I don't really care about making money
but how do I
- Live?
- How do I keep doing what I want to do?
- I'll be very honest with you
on some straight intuition shit,
I don't think you're
hearing 'em that much.
Just even the way you asked the question.
- Okay.
- I'm being dead serious with you.
I listen very carefully and I'm more
vibes than I am the words.
I actually don't think you're
hearing them that much.
I think you want to be respectful to them.
I think you have a good
vibe about this question.
It's gonna be your life
at the end, anyway.
Let me tell you one thing about
teaching or anything else that
doesn't make you fuckin'
a million dollars a year.
The most upset, not happy people I know
have the most money that I know.
We need to start changing the
conversation to happiness,
not money.
You can make $47,000 a year
and have much more stuff
than somebody who makes 280,
it depends on how much you spend.
You might not be in a position to buy
every new off white,
on a teacher's salary.
But the question is, do you need that?
The reality is,
most people need it just to flex
in front of somebody
'cause they're insecure.
Once you don't give a fuck
about anybody's opinion,
you don't need shit.
You ain't gonna buy anything.
You need nothing.
That's straight up,
man, young guys buy shit
'cause they're insecure.
They wanna look cool in
front of their friends,
they wanna get a girl.
It's not super complicated.
Least complicated shit of all time.
That's why you want all the shit you want.
The end.
Once you don't want that,
one thing I will tell you
about making money and teaching,
the current state of the
way we package education
will continue to evolve.
In my heart, I think this man right here
is gonna look at the
same teacher that he is
in some kid in 71 years,
and he's gonna look at them
the same way that
Dominique Wilkins or Moses Malone
or Hall of Famers look at players now.
These guys walk around
when they're 57, 63,
80 years old,
they were the best players of their time,
and they're watching
scrubs sit on the bench
making more money in one week
than they made in their whole career,
I believe the way education
is packaged and sold
in the future,
I think he'll make $4,000,000 a year.
He just won't, 'cause
he missed his timing.
But as the internet evolves,
he's gonna teach direct, get paid direct.
I believe that.
I do believe that.
- [Man] Start a YouTube channel.
(laughs)
- You know what I mean?
So your parents and the world are right,
if you decide to go and work
in a public school system,
you probably won't make the most money.
If you decide to be a teacher
that does it virtually,
'cause you're such a young man in 21 years
and that's how people
actually get educated,
and parents pay you directly,
you might make fuckin' $7,000,000 a year.
- [Woman] There's already
a school model like that.
You literally hire what you want
as an educator
- Yeah.
- [Woman] And it's a one to one situation.
- Of course, entrepreneurs
weren't cool 20 years ago.
People didn't make money rappin'.
- [Man] So I'm really into fashion,
styling and stuff like that
- Yep, yep.
- [Man] I started my side hustle
with my friend and stuff,
they pay me and I will
when they go out to parties,
I'll pick out clothes for them
or they give me a budget
and I'll go out and
- [Gary] You'll make the fat
they'll give you 200, you'll spend 160.
- Yeah, I'll make
- [Gary] I fuckin' love it.
Okay.
- And I was just wondering,
because most the people I do it for,
they tell their friend about it
- [Gary] Yeah, it's word of mouth.
- Yeah so how do I market
what I'm doing more?
- Let's take a step back.
Is your thought that in seven years,
if you live in L.A. making a lot of money
styling people, that would be fresh?
How are you thinking about it?
- [Man] It's not really more for money,
I just really like
fashion, clothes in general
- Yeah.
- [Man] I find it fun and
an interesting thing to do,
and I like
- The thrill of the hunt of the clothes
against who you're gonna
dress is fun as shit.
- [Man] I can see them in this, or
- So one more time.
Do you wanna be a
stylist when you grow up?
- [Man] Possibly yeah.
- A couple things.
One, it's no different
than the music advice.
You should DM Ben Simmons and be like,
I want to dress you.
And if he's in a weird mood,
he might just say yes.
I don't think people understand,
all you need is one yes!
I can't believe people are
willing to play the lottery
every day, but not DM people.
People would rather try
to go to the casino,
turning stone and take that ride
with four of their buddies and $80 bucks,
than DM people.
It's a much better lottery!
So anyway, that's one,
and two, the other thing I would do
if I were you,
and it was similar to
the advice I gave him
but yours is even more direct,
do you know, do you follow 50 to 100
of the biggest stylists in L.A.?
- [Man] No.
- I think you should.
If you ask me, I would go Google
on the bus ride home right now,
'top 100 stylists',
go follow all of them on Instagram.
See who you think is fresh,
and then DM those 57 and say,
I want to intern for you for free,
and then, when one of them
miraculously says yes,
and you're like, fuck,
how do I get to L.A. now?
This goes back to just grinding.
Go on Craigslist and
live on somebody's floor!
Either you want it or you don't.
Guys, I'm gonna say it one more time.
From 20,
from 14, but, fuck it.
From 22 to 34, I worked every day.
I went out no weekends,
I worked every day.
Every day, for fuckin' 12 years
to build my parents' liquor business,
and left at 34 with nothing.
With part ownership of the
land the liquor store's on
but with a huge mortgage.
Which means I'm underwater.
With a salary I paid myself
even though I built it
from 3 to $60 million,
that I never paid myself any real money.
Started over at 34
after building a $60
million dollar business!
Patience.
And if you want it, you want it!
I wanted it!
First I wanted to pay back my parents
for taking me from Russia
and giving me this opportunity,
and being the best parents.
All that love and wisdom
that they put in me
is why I can give it to you now!
I had to pay that back,
I didn't want that debt on my shoulders.
I wanted to really pay
back my parents, for real.
And now I'm doing me!
And I started at 34.
And I'm 43 and I'm a kid.
I'm a kid, and you guys
think I'm old as fuck!
So think about how young you really are.
You know what I mean?
At 17, 43 felt like dead.
Like dead.
When I was 22 and came
out, my cousin was 30,
I thought he was the oldest fucker.
Old!
So I know exactly how you're feeling.
But one day you're gonna
be sitting here at 43
and you can see the heads nodding.
You're gonna feel exactly the same.
I feel the same fuckin' fire, energy,
optimism, ambition, heat
that I did when I was a Junior
and Senior in high school.
Same shit.
Same person.
Same!
(laughs)
When you,
if you,
if one of you actually internalized it
and said that's true,
you'll get patient, man,
you want to talk about not stressin'
about the next five or 10 years,
if you actually felt what I just said,
and you believed it,
which I know is hard, I get it.
It's like,
changing perspective's hard.
But if you believed it,
you'd be patient as fuck!
You wouldn't be so stressed!
Be like, shit!
He's talkin' like that,
you're 17?
- 18.
- 18,
you're like, okay.
Double my age, I'm gonna be 36.
I'm gonna live my life
completely over again
from the get!
(snaps)
And I'm gonna be 36
which is seven years younger
than he is right now!
And he's talkin' like that.
It slows down.
You know how they talk about sports?
Athletes like to talk about,
year three they're like, yo!
Why are you having such a good season?
Something happened,
everything just slowed down.
Right?
That's how life gets too.
Not just sports.
Just all of a sudden slows down.
- [Man] Can I ask you,
when somebody says no, right?
- Yeah.
I like that.
(laughs)
- I love no's.
- No is the best!
- I mean I've gotten no's
in my life, of course
- Everybody got no's!
If you didn't get no's,
you guys would be dating somebody
completely different right now!
(laughs)
- I asked a brand about
could I do something for 'em,
the same thing you said about
- Yeah, yeah.
- Finding a business,
the business is terrible
- Yep.
- I took that, and I asked them,
listen, I think they do
figurines for horror movies.
And I said, I want to work for you
but these are my hours.
I want to do this,
I don't really want nothing,
I just want to do it for you.
- They said no.
- They left me,
yeah, said no.
And so, what they did was they reversed it
and they ended up saying, alright,
you can do this like a program.
You get paid for it.
I didn't want to get paid,
I just wanted to do it.
- Yeah.
- See what they said.
- Move on.
- I did.
- Yeah!
What do I think about it?
Nothing.
Good.
(laughs)
What?
What, what, what?
What do I think about it?
Nothing!
I mean, are you kidding me?
People, literally I'm watching people
take all my content, build businesses
and then shit on me.
To try to build themselves up.
I see everything!
None of it bothers me,
do yours, what the fuck?
Has nothing to do with me.
Just keep doin' it!
Keep choppin'.
On them fucking you over,
is a second that you're
not spending on offense.
Looking backwards fucks with your neck.
(laughs)
It just does.
Right?
Like, what?
There's nothing anybody here can,
the most cliche shit,
what are gonna tell me?
Your dad killed somebody and is in jail?
You lost your parent?
That's real as fuck.
The problem is, it happened.
You just can't, you just have no prayer.
It doesn't mean that people don't have
sympathy and compassion.
Lots of people have
sympathy and compassion
and empathy for those things.
You just can't do anything about it.
What?
I can't go back and
stop that electric fire
that made you go homeless for six months.
By the way,
we're going cliche, urban, tougher.
People cry in my face,
they're like, my grandfather
left me $50 million,
this is real!
I keep telling you this,
you guys hear it from me
if you're paying attention.
My grandfather left me, crying,
my grandfather left me $50 million,
and no matter what I do my whole life,
whatever I do my whole life,
nobody will say I did it.
I was handed it.
And you know what?
That makes sense to him,
because he wants to do
something he wants to do.
It's gonna make more sense to him
based on his question.
Do I expect somebody who's
fucking got no money,
struggled their whole life
to cry for the person
that got $50 million?
Of course not!
'Cause that's what they're trying to get!
But there's a lot of people
that were handed everything
who now know they can't hide,
and everybody knows they
were handed everything,
money.
Thus, anything they do,
'nah'.
That would've killed me.
That would've killed me, from the get.
So it's just perspective.
I just believe your adversity is
your fuckin' foundation of success.
I really do.
I really, really do, I really
I don't know what
I don't think I'm delusional.
My big thing is if you've
ever seen anybody do it,
then you can too!
If anybody looks like you that did it,
Why'd they do it?
Why'd they get out?
Right?
People just give up before they start.
- That's my problem with me.
My dad would tell me, you always,
I would go through stuff in school
my grades were slipping,
he tells me I just gotta keep fighting.
- That's good.
- He tells me every day
before he goes to work,
every time I'm struggling in school
- You need to
- I would just give up before,
I would struggle with school
since elementary school,
I would always give up after
getting a question wrong on a test,
failing a quiz,
then I got better and better.
I'll have my moments when I slip up
but then I'll be like,
I can't keep letting this thing get to me.
I gotta get myself back up
and gotta keep fighting and go on.
- You need to kiss that man in the face.
You need to go home tonight
and kiss that man in the face.
I mean it!
(laughs)
I mean it, man!
(applauding)
- Dad, if you're watching
this, I love you!
- That's real, man!
That's real.
That's fuckin' real, man.
You're lucky you have someone.
There's a lot of people
that don't have that in their life!
- He tells me that all the time.
He says, you don't know
how lucky you are, son.
- He's right, 'cause he
knows the alternative.
Every generation had it worse.
Don't get it twisted.
- I think that's the value
of this, really, Gary.
Back to what I said in the beginning,
if you see it, you can be it idea.
- Five.
- Kind of being
(laughs)
even being in the space
of what's going on here
and what you've built
- Do me a favor, grab out to Nick
and find out when we do my Q&A part,
I know there's some comps,
let's make sure we do the people that
not first, second.
- So just being in the space
where people want to be
and they want to work.
Being off the block for a minute and
in the boardroom, right?
It's a
- And don't put the
boardroom on a pedestal.
Don't put this fuckin'
place on a pedestal.
- [Man] No it's the energy.
- No the energy's good
and this place is the best
I'm the best, I get it.
(laughs)
But, recognize the block
is your foundation.
You know, I mean it.
It's so valuable.
I mean it!
Grit is rare now.
We didn't pay the piper in 2009.
Guys,
you're coming back 18 months later.
I can't wait to see you fuckers in 14,
27 years, you're gonna be like, fuck,
you were so right, you don't understand
how much your fuckin'
adversity is your foundation.
The internet is neutral!
Everybody here should be
selling shit on the internet.
- Can I ask you something else?
What do you think about
- [Gary] Yeah, man you have so much shit
people hit me up, they're like,
I ain't got,
we're in America.
You're rich as fuck by
comparison to a lot of people in
'seven seven' in the world.
7.7 billion, it's contextual.
Maybe not in the best part of Philly.
But, look, this is America.
If you have shit,
if you have shit in your closet
that you don't wear, you got money.
- Plenty of stuff I never even
touched.
- [Man] Older, older
cats from the old school
- Yeah.
- Try to talk to
our generation, talking to us now,
how do you feel about that?
'Cause I feel like, especially with rap,
I know a lot of rappers
don't want to listen to
what the older folks have to say.
- You have to synthesize everything.
Even me.
Everybody, everybody,
you have to synthesize their perspective.
There's so much value
to get out of the old
'cause some shit is tried and true.
But then you have to synthesize shit
when they're saying stuff out of
them being sad that they're
not in their prime anymore.
So you have to synthesize,
this is about you synthesizing.
Not everything I said
here is right for you.
You have to synthesize.
- Yeah 'cause I take that from both rap
and I take it from both media
and even down to comedy,
like Richard Pryor,
he basically escalated comedy
and younger folks will still tell you.
- That's my guy.
If you carefully watch me give a keynote,
the one hour shit I put on YouTube,
that's Richard Pryor, Eddie
Murphy and Chris Rock.
- See!
This is why
- 100 percent.
Even the way I fuckin',
if you watch the cadence of how I deliver,
I'm like, fuck,
I was really affected by those fuckers.
- You know.
- Richard Pryor.
I mean, listen, I played that tape out.
(laughs)
Tape.
- [Man] Eddie Murphy, Raw was for me.
That was the one.
- [Man] Delirious.
- [Gary] Classics.
- [Man] Ice cream truck, bro.
(laughs)
- Legend.
Let me sneak one or two more in.
Who hasn't asked a
question, I'll answer it.
- So I'm the same with Amir,
I want to be a teacher.
- Okay.
- That's my whole thing,
that's my whole goal.
- Yes, okay.
- But the thing is,
with being a teacher,
especially a Black teacher,
'cause there are like, none,
you feel me?
It's so rare.
It's like
a golden goose, you feel me?
- Where?
- It's so rare.
- It's not as rare as you'd think.
- Really?
- Yeah, your perspective's limited.
- Well, yeah.
- Let's start with that.
'Cause that matters!
Because if that's your framework,
then you're on a different course.
Then you're already thinking,
oh shit, I gotta win the lotto,
and I'm like, nah, not really.
Not really.
There's plenty of
African-American teachers
in the world.
There's lots of Black teachers.
Whole lot.
Lots and lots.
- Well I can count on both my hands
how many teachers I have
- Of course, you go to one fuckin' school!
- Nah.
- 13, I don't give a fuck.
(laughs)
You went to .0001 percent of the schools
in this fuckin' country,
I know I'm right, motherfucker.
(laughs)
You went to 13 schools!
There's fuckin' 40,000 schools!
You're keepin' it tight but
in support, let me tell you something,
both of you.
And teaching I think is up
I'm doing it, in my way.
Two things.
One, once you start thinking it's limited,
it's gonna change your framework,
by the way, it might be your strength.
That might drive you to get it done.
So I don't want to take it away,
I just want to make sure
you're dealing in truth,
right?
Two, you got to ask yourself
when you decided you
wanted to be a teacher.
And this is just
not about teaching,
if you said you wanted to
be a multi-trillionaire.
You're so young,
I'm comin'.
You're so young that
you need to make sure that
when you decided your thing,
have you evolved since?
Ideology is very dangerous.
If you put in your head too early
'cause it's where you limited yourself
or where it was most comfortable,
or because you loved your
fourth grade teacher,
just be thoughtful,
you're evolving every day.
I say that to these two!
They're both young too.
Just keep evolving.
That's just something I want to say
for all of you.
Anyway, keep going.
- So my whole thing is,
I don't care.
I mean, money is a factor, yeah.
But, that's my main priority.
- Good.
- You feel me?
When I become a teacher,
I want to try and make an impact
with students so they can be a positive
- Yeah, yeah of course.
- Reynolds' been a
positive impact in my life
since Freshman year.
- Makes sense.
- You feel me?
- I do.
- I want to be like
that for other students
for other kids.
- Yeah.
- I want to be like a healthy,
positive role model for them.
- Amazing.
Amazing.
- The bread's anything,
I can come up with money
from another job.
But a teacher is something special.
Okay cool, I'm your
educator, I'm your mentor,
I can be anything you want to be,
just gotta let me in.
- So what's the question?
Statement?
- Yeah.
- Love it, feel it.
- You already answered my question,
you feel me?
- Yeah, I love it.
(laughs)
- [Man] I got a question
how it pertains to the
majority of the students
- Okay.
- [Man] People in this room.
Maybe you already answered
it in some type of way
- That's alright, go ahead.
- [Man] Us being Seniors,
most of us are going to college
- Okay.
- [Man] What are the biggest
advice you can give us?
- How many people are going to college?
Raise your hand, just curious.
How many of the people
that are going to college
are taking on debt?
You're gonna have to take
debt to go to college,
raise it.
- [Woman] Who still has debt from college?
(laughs)
- That's my first piece of advice.
This is real as fuck.
Everybody who just raised their hand,
you have to ask yourself
why you're going to college.
I'm being serious.
I know it's a tricky one,
this is where I take heat
but I'm sayin', if you're not a student,
I was not a student.
I would have not went to Mount Ida College
which was,
I'm being nice calling it a college.
(laughs)
But if my parents didn't pay for it,
and that's what they wanted
and I was cool with it,
'cause I knew I had one last vacation
before I was gonna work the
rest of my fuckin' life,
I wouldn't have went.
I'm very scared
that everybody just
blindly goes to college,
'cause that's the American Dream,
and that's what's gonna put you on,
and they take on that debt,
and then that college
degree doesn't put them on.
Now, you have to have a
viable option.
If I start a seed here,
and your parents are gonna be mad at me,
and you decide not to go to college,
you gotta work.
It's not like you'll sit around.
But, my first piece of advice, my man,
is if you're taking on debt,
and you're not going
to a top 10, 15, 20, 30
maybe top 100 university,
which is gonna give you leverage
when you get out
to get a job that might pay for the debt
that you're incurring,
you gotta debate.
You gotta debate.
If you are, then it's different.
But even the top school,
it's crazy what's happening so fast.
Because companies in the world
are no longer requiring college.
Debt is real.
Interest rates are real on it.
People are,
do you know how many kids in here
look like everything's great
are $140,000 in debt under water,
making $64,000 a year?
Not saving shit?
- [Woman] So many of them,
when we were asking their history,
how they got here and all of that.
A lot of 'em said,
they have degrees that they just
don't even use.
It's just not
- Nobody uses their degree!
10 percent, 30 percent, 40 percent,
but nonetheless, debt.
Debt's the first thing I'm worried about.
After that, the people.
There's nobody in this room
and out here going to a college that
is gonna teach them
something in the classroom
that isn't available on
the internet for free.
- [Man] YouTube University.
(laughs)
- It's scary.
But, who you meet, things like that nature
but you can do that on DM,
you can go
the people are the ROI.
But the people you can
get in real life too.
Without the debt.
Gotta know yourself, gotta be self-aware.
If you're not a real student,
if you don't learn like that,
just goin' there because
it's making your mom happy,
or you think it's the right thing to do,
if you're taking on debt
you need to reset.
I mean it.
I know that's,
I know, but,
fuck, the results speak.
- [Man] Explain the ROI for guys
that don't understand.
- Return On Investment.
You're gonna spend a hund-o?
Or $63,000 or $49,000 in debt
but you're compounding
seven, 12 percent interest
after you get out,
and you get a job that pays you
College was amazing from the fuckin' '40,
'50s to '90s because your degree
put you on to the job!
You got an Accounting degree and
submit it in,
some Accounting firm took you!
Just not happening anymore!
The same way.
I don't know.
That's bad.
If you're taking on debt.
If you invest in something,
all that time and money, and
you come out the other end,
and it's not there for you,
what?
That's what I keep
You go to college?
You goin' to college?
Okay, so to me,
great, enjoy, amazing.
But even if you went to
FIT or what have you,
interning for the three biggest designers
in that same four year period
where they pay you five bucks and hour,
or nothing,
to become a big time stylist
is far more likely that path!
Being a student and coming out
and trying to get a job versus
when you're the right hand of the fuckin'
hottest stylist just 'cause
you're carrying coffee
but then when you're stylin' fuckin,
LeBron,
and they're like, shit, he's talented!
That's real life!
That's real life.
So, self awareness would be
my first advice on college.
Second, if you decide
listen, that's a big leap.
If you been on a course where
again, cliche shit,
you're gonna be the first one ever go
or this and this, I get it!
It's a lot to just give up on,
'cause it's been in your
head the whole time.
If you go, people.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello,
friends, friends, different friends.
My favorite thing I've
talked about recently
was I went to USC and spoke to them.
I'm coming out, I'm sorry.
I spoke to the USC Football team,
I walked in there, I said,
motherfuckers, you think you're special.
You think you're cool.
I go, 98 percent of you
are not going in the League.
This is it!
This is the apex of your life.
This is the coolest, best you'll ever be.
And I go, and you're
walking into class at USC.
With your fuckin' hoodie on,
and your Beats, and talkin' to nobody.
Meanwhile, everybody in your classroom
is gonna run Hollywood in five years.
20 years.
Wake the fuck up.
That's how I think about this.
Every kid you don't know in school
you should know.
People is the game.
Especially in high school,
everyone's just making fun of each other,
trying to be cool.
Making fun of people
that could put them on
in 10 years!
- [Man] True.
- Everybody who made fun of me
made a big fuckin' mistake.
(laughs)
Yep.
What's that, brother?
- [Man] Internships?
- [Gary] Yep.
Listen, we're taking internships
and one of you guys can have one.
- [Man] I want one.
- [Gary] Well, we're gonna have to,
listen, we're gonna have to figure out
how we're gonna do that contest.
- [Man] You also date 'em,
just in case I decide to flip 'em?
- [Gary] Yep, what is it today?
(laughs)
Nine, 22nd?
2/22.
Yeah man.
- [Man] I noticed that
you a Wrestling fan.
- Big.
- So am I.
- That's what's up, man.
You guys come to my office, do your thing,
I'll see you guys in a
little bit before I leave.
Alright, let's go.
Where are we going?
- [Man] Bro, I love you.
- [Gary] How behind am I, 30?
How much?
- [Woman] 45.